welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is deadlifts friends a senior scientist
with the research domain
transdisciplinary concepts and methods
at Potsdam Institute for climate impact
research in Germany he is currently at
Yale as a Rice faculty fellow in the
European studies counsel at the
Macmillan Center and a visiting
professor in the Department of Political
Science and at the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies today
we'll talk with professors friends about
the effectiveness of climate clubs
welcome professors friends well thank
you for inviting me let's start with the
term climate Club it's not something
that I'm familiar with so explain what a
club is and and perhaps why a club is
used in terms of the country well let's
locate it properly the climate
laboratory refers to climate mitigation
and incentives to do so it's not about
adaptation meaning coping with the
effects like any of the hurricanes or
compensation meaning dealing with
whatever isn't being mitigated and
damages or adapted - so let's go to
climate mitigation claps okay if we
mitigate we create worldwide global
public goods that is anybody benefits
from the emissions never emitted meaning
avoided damages that sometimes when
quite often may not be enough to give
incentives for countries to reduce their
greenhouse gas emissions so if they have
additional effects in additional
benefits I should say like a club good
and I will explain this this would give
them additional impetus to join a group
of other countries to do the same think
of a tennis club you normally want to
play tennis there is a tennis ground but
there is normally a lot of demand and so
they normally put a fence around the
signup sheet and ask you for a
membership fee
here's the same but in return for paying
all of that in this case spending 1% of
GDP on mitigation per year you get
additional trade benefits that are only
for members and not for non-members so
it's members only benefits okay and
let's talk about the the that term in
reality so in terms of you know what
countries belong to these clubs well
first of all in reality many informal
networks call themselves climate labs
they're mostly talk shops and maybe
coordination collapse for some let's say
research and development at very very
best so we build on the literature and a
proposition by David Victor of the
University of California at San Diego he
suggested that we build incentive
structures from the bottom up for
countries to undertake something
together but we are not sort of speak
only terrible we think about countries
as essentially looking after their own
welfare right so in that sense the clubs
are an ideal climate clubs are an idea
to reconcile global public benefits with
incentives for countries ok and what are
some of the incentives typically the
incentives are typically to generate
welfare that hopefully spreads widely in
the country in order to generate
political support
so preferential trade access is one of
those in previous government and
actually also as I hear in the preffer
in the current government ok and how
what conditions would a climate club
emerge and grow well we look at a range
of factors and all of this our agent
based model meaning computational models
that calibrate in a non arbitrary way
where a country stands and what might
happen if it relates to others in a
specific way so what are the incentives
for one we know what it costs them to
mitigate in a simplified way and
sorry what do you mean by mitigate
mitigate is reducing greenhouse gas
emissions okay
and they can take essentially three
different roles they're a leader meaning
they are the front-runners alone or
another big emitter and the three ones
we look at are the US China and the
European Union of 28 and whether they go
alone or with any of the others these
are the starting configurations and they
locate Adi in the ends themselves better
off joining a club and staying it up
meaning to follow us emerge and if they
are better off with the club then
without they will stay in the other role
is they could be followers meaning not
one of those three potential threes and
in that case these countries only look
am I better off joining or not not that
the group of all is better but am I
better off joining or not and the third
role that they potentially take is
abstainers or outsiders meaning I don't
want to have to do anything with this
and I stressed the outside okay
let's talk about the the second two
groups you mentioned not the leaders but
the people who are the countries who are
abstaining or are considering whether to
join or not let's start with the
abstainers what countries have you
looked at that that have said you know I
have no interest in being a part of this
or it's not worthwhile for our country
to participate abstainers well there's
only one famous case it's the Trump
speech in the Rose Garden on June the
1st of this year in 2017 where he
announced he wants to leave the Paris
agreement we did not model exactly the
Paris agreement we started modeling
already in November December of last
year after we heard who was elected and
what does it mean if one of the big
players is potentially leaving the role
as a leader so we looked at it what
happens if the u.s. becomes a follower
and third one if it becomes an outsider
it does want to stay outside if it wants
to stay outside and we could do this
also if charge the you want to choose
this rule or if
China would choose this role but we have
only done it so far for the US so the
results are roughly as this it becomes
somewhat more difficult to build a
credible climate mitigation Club I that
doesn't preclude like say a coalition of
the EU and China to emerge but anything
where the US would be the leader is of
course now omitted from the choice set
the level at which a club would grow now
a necessity it's normally higher club
good benefits to compensate for the loss
of the US and of course and a certain
and a whole range of configurations the
u.s. is now missing meaning roughly 14
percentage points of emissions are
missing under many configurations on a
few occasions
if there is an abstainer like the US
could be then a few others may follow
like Brazil and other medium-sized
countries but also sometimes means then
that India comes in which is the fourth
biggest emitter okay so it is not that
the u.s. can overcome the incentives
other countries have but certainly it
will be missed okay
and you look at two conceptual
approaches to the study of climate
policy of major countries interest based
and then also which is augmented by the
domestic political situation there can
you talk a little bit about that
particularly perhaps China and the
United States mmm-hmm
well first of all what is the interest
based explanation it's an incredibly
simple classification system and it
looks at two factors how ecologically
vulnerable mi for instance to climate
change and second is what are the cost
of mitigation and if you have low
mitigation costs and high ecological
vulnerability you are most likely being
poor and international negotiations if
you have high costs and low
environmental benefits for whatever you
do obviously you are likely to be a
dragger and there of course I'm in
between categories so we ran for the six
major countries of the world we
models and looked at data to classify
countries and we predicted that for
instance China is a dragger and that
actually there would be no pusher then
we compared it to the actual diplomatic
record and of course we found that there
are a few errors in our predictions but
that highlighted why domestic politics
is so important because it's a Mac it's
a modifier of these macro quantitative
kind of simple classification system so
we look at popularity of climate change
policies in the country we looked at
they are industries that make benefit
from renewable energy or their own
exports of renewable energy providers
think of China China has flooded the
market with photovoltaic equipment so
it's not only the German producers go
out of business but even Indian
producers go out of business because
China has just achieved such a huge
scale of production that their per unit
costs are very very low on the other
hand you find even states in the US that
are very enthusiastic about some sort of
climate policy or let's call the
renewable energy portfolios so for some
time Texas is a leading country as state
excuse me
it has rolled out renewable energy on a
scale that took everything everybody
else by breath and so we have it also in
part on the east and on the west coast
depending on which state it is of course
there's a California effect in general
the u.s. position of being a kind of
intermediate enthusiasm was not correct
under Obama - meaning especially his
activities in his last four years he was
certainly the country was a leader in
international negotiations although it
started already in 2009 with trying to
engage China and then under secretary
Kerry who she now in Campos it of course
was even enhanced further but if we look
at the Trump administration the
hesitations are more than obvious so it
certainly is not a leader on the global
scale anymore this begs the question
what is a Virgina
when Trump made his announcement on June
1st of this year China responded it
sticks by its obligations and since it's
the biggest emitter in the world of
greenhouse gases we have to see if the
EU and China will do something together
and if they are by default the remaining
leaders do you think India will step up
to the plate this is extremely good
question it was hesitant until Paris and
if I'm not mistaken the US did a
behind-the-scenes deal in order to get
into India on renewable energy which
India is passionate about not because
they necessarily like at least on the
international scale climate change
protection to an extremely high extent
but they need energy
they are fastly growing they have huge
intermittent sirs if that you will find
any time you do a Skype conversation
with India and the generators go on
because intermittency comes in and also
if you live there and I have lived there
you have always protection against
intermittency but they like any source
of renewable energy however India has
public tenders for photovoltaics but
especially winds that are of such a low
price that you wonder how they do it it
may be that they do not always follow
through the investors on their promises
but the prices are so attractive that
renewables clearly beats coal in new
installations and what about solar
energy I mean in this country I think
there's a huge push for solar energy do
you think that will have an effect
moving forward on how countries work
together well I don't know exactly the
production costs here and how if you
protect yourself against the imports of
Chinese panels and then there's
concentrated solar where you have lots
of experimental sites in some of the
deserts here which are of course very
important with panels the
prices have come so much down over the
last 10 years that if one looks at the
price level and solves the intermittency
problem in the problem of if there is no
wind in this case for wind power or no
Sun for some power you need some sort of
buffer in between but once you solve
that I think even for the u.s. it's
looking at renewables it's not a net
cost but in the long run a net benefit
it also saves you a little bit on your
transmission lines you don't have really
a nationally integrated grid so these
sources of energy are decentralized that
helps with the current installations
quite a bit okay and do you think the in
the u.s. can influence the effectiveness
of climate clubs and if so how best to
do that well in some sense the Trump
government has decided to abstain so in
that sense it makes it for the rest of
the world more difficult because the
leader is missing and of course
everybody recognizes it however if the
US would go domestic and alone and would
sort of speak say we want to now be the
real competitors of the Chinese because
we roll out a domestic program there's
no reason not to believe that American
entrepreneurial ISM both on the business
case side as well as on the technology
side could not be a very viable
competitor in fact that would be nice to
see because why shouldn't there be a
competition for charitable and
profitable ends right so what do you see
for the future of climate clubs being I
mean do you think there will be more of
them created or do you think less well
given the what the Trump this
administration decided in the middle of
this year it of course makes it more
difficult as compared to an Obama - I
think one shouldn't be pessimistic I
think the rest of the world at least
some of the major players will not try
to be inter discouraged and there's of
course the question which generates the
wealth of tomorrow
is it coal iron and
deal or is it renewable energy and these
types of technologies and I think the
betters on the letter not on the former
and to your point to that point I think
even if the United States is becomes
more of a follower and not a leader I
think perhaps the rest of the world in
terms of the people in those countries
to your point about domestic politics
can rise up and have renewable sources
of energy become more prominent part of
the roles that they play in the
countries well first of all this country
is a federal state and that means some
part of the country are much more
ambitious on climate policies and the
federal government is true and if you
look at the East Coast and the West
Coast and the related Canadian provinces
there's much more enthusiasm than in
other parts of this country and in on
Capitol Hill right so in that sense
there's no reason to be discouraged so
when I was living in Missoula Montana
you could buy at Whole Foods literally a
share of renewable energy plan and they
have I supported it was just you go to
the checkout and you do it in a minor
way and actually the community of or the
the city government of Missoula Montana
even offered you public recognition for
it if you wanted so by putting you on a
nice web page so as a climate pioneer so
California tries to do its policy and
Governor Brown was here recently in town
and clearly the physician to himself so
that the governor of the state of
Washington and there are others so
there's no reason to despair about the
US because there's also a lot of
entrepreneurialism and the only thing
that a European should really fear in
terms of competition is that the
Americans have the better business
models because Europe is mostly
state-led or heavy reliance on the role
of the state here most likely in the US
it will be more in the business sector
with of course some framework laws by
the federal and the state governments
but good entrepreneurialism cannot be
substituted for and there's a lot of
this in this country ultimately do you
think the climate clubs will be able to
reduce emissions well first of all these
are model results so ultimately if we
want to see if they really emerge we
would have to wait in history but I
would have to become very all to do a
proper evaluation but as a scientist
that's really what patience is called
for but what the what is the real value
of this model is to show the enduring
incentives however we have also
configuration when they die so it's not
that this is morally or driven by hope
these are numerical results based on
real input data as we get them from the
World Bank from the University of Notre
Dame and others so the hope is there but
there are no assurances but there's one
thing climate rain especially
anthropogenic the influence climate rain
is extremely unlikely to go away so even
if we don't mitigate we do have an
adaptation issue and as Huston has shown
compared to the Caribbean islands the
damages are severe but by far not as
severe in as many of the Caribbean
countries so these parts of the US are
much better shielded economic
development helps and whether you
believe or not believe in climate change
all of Florida Louisiana and Texas will
think hard about what to do so when I
gave a presentation in Alaska I think it
was in 2011 I saw members of the u.s.
Navy showing up in uniform speaking on
climate change and the George W Bush
excuse me it was after it was Obama I
think it was still during the time of
Bush so I may be mistaken for the year
but this person stood up and said we
don't care whether this is man-made or
non man-made we have to plan for our
ports if they're sea-level rise you know
we have a management problem if you lose
our ports and this is our sea power so
taking it into a cloud into account for
our planning of the future
infrastructure is just good professional
management and
I take that as good evidence that people
think very sober about what they have to
do in the future and especially if they
build long-term infrastructure the
incentives are there to to think far
ahead right especially just with the
recent hurricanes that have been
happening I think more and more people
it's becoming more and more an issue so
important work thank you so much for
being here with us today thank you very
much for more information about
Professor Sprint's and his research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale.edu be sure to join us again
for another episode of the Macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale
[Music]